before this covid thing you and Brad had
some good conversations I would say
we're friends what's your what do you
admire most about Brett outside of all
the criticism we've had about this
covert topic
well I think Brett is very smart and
he's a very um ethical person who wants
good things for the world I mean I have
no reason to doubt that so the fact that
we're on you know we're cross-wise on
this issue is not does not mean that I
think he's
a bad person I mean the thing that
worried me about what he was doing
and this was true of Joe and this was
true of Elon is the true of many other
people is that once you're messaging at
scale
to a vast audience
you incur a certain kind of
responsibility not to to get people
killed and I do I did worry that
yeah people were people were making
decisions on the basis of the
information that was getting shared
there and that that's why I was
I think fairly circumspect I just said
okay give me the the
center of the Fairway expert opinion at
this time point and at this time point
at this time point
and then I'm out right I don't have any
more to say about this I'm not an expert
on covet I'm not an expert on it the
safety of mRNA vaccines
um
if something if something changes so as
to become newsworthy then maybe I'll do
a podcast so I mean I just did a podcast
on collably right like I was never
skeptical of the lab Lake hypothesis
Brett was very early on saying this is
this is a lab leak right
um at a point where my only position was
who cares if it's a lab leak right like
this there's the thing we have to get
straight is what do we do given the
nature of this pandemic but also we
should say that you've actually stated
that it is a possibility oh yeah you
just said it doesn't doesn't it I mean
it the time to figure that out now I've
actually I have had my my podcast guest
on this topic changed my view of this
because you know one of the guests uh
Elena Chan made the point that you know
actually that the best time to figure
out the origin of this is immediately
right because in the Abbott you lose
touch with the evidence and I hadn't
really been thinking about that like I
didn't if you come back after a year
um
you know there are certain facts you
might not be able to get in hand but
I've always felt that it didn't matter
for two reasons one is
we had the Genome of the virus and and
we could design we're very quickly
designed immediately designing vaccines
against that genome and that's what we
had to do and then we had to figure out
how to vaccinate and to
and to mitigate and to develop
treatments and all that
so the origin story didn't matter
generically speaking
either or origin story was
politically inflammatory and made the
Chinese look bad right and the Chinese
response to this look bad whatever the
origin story right they're not
cooperating
they're letting they're stopping their
domestic flights but letting their
international flights go I mean it's
just they were bad actors and they
should be treated as such regardless of
the origin right and you know I would
argue that the wet Market origin is even
more politically invidious than the lab
League origin I mean why do you think
because for lab leak to my eye
the lab leak could happen to anyone
right we're all running all these
Advanced countries are running these
dangerous labs
as a practice that we should be worried
about you know in general
we know lab leaks are a problem there
have been multiple lab leaks of even
worse things that haven't gotten out of
hand in this way but you know worse
pathogens
um
we're
we're wise to be worried about this and
on some level it could happen to anyone
right the wet Market makes them look
like barbarians live in another Century
like you got to clean up those wet
markets like what are you what are you
doing putting a bat on top of a Pangolin
on top of a duck it's like get your
together so like if anything
the wet Market makes them look worse in
my view now I'm sure there's I'm sure
that what they actually did to conceal a
lab leak if it was a lab leak all of
that's going to look odious
um do you think we'll ever get to the
bottom of that I mean one of the big
negative
um I would say failures of Anthony fauci
and so on is to be transparent and clear
and it's just a good communicator about
getting functional research the dangers
of that the success like the you know
why it's a useful way of research but
it's also dangerous right you know just
being transparent about that as opposed
to just coming off really shady of
course the conspiracy theorists and the
the politicians are not helping but this
just created a
giant mess yeah no I would agree that so
that exchange with fauci and Rand Paul
that went viral yeah I would agree that
fauci looked like he was
taking refuge in kind of very lawyered
language
and not
giving a straightforward account of what
we do and why we do it and so yeah I
think it looked Shady it played shady
and it probably was shady I mean I don't
know how personally entangled he is with
any of this but
yeah the gain of function research is
something that
I think we're wise to be worried about
and insofar as I judge myself adequate
to have an opinion on this
I think it should be banned right like I
I I'm probably a podcast I'll do you
know if you or somebody else doesn't do
it in the meantime
um
you know I I would like a virologist on
to defend it against a virologist who
who who would uh criticize it forget
about the gain a function research
I don't even understand virus hunting at
this point it's like I don't know I
don't even know why you need to go into
a cave to find this next virus that
could be circulating among bats that may
jump zoonotically to us
why do that when we can make when we
when we can seek once in a day and and
make vaccines in a weekend I mean like
like what kind of Head Start do you
think you're getting that's a surprising
new thing how quickly you can develop a
vaccine exactly that's uh
yeah that's that's really interesting
but the shadiness around lab League
I think the point I didn't make about
Brett's style of engaging this issue is
people are using the fact that he was
early on lab leak to suggest that he was
right about Ivermectin and about mRNA
vaccines and all the rest like no that
that's
none of that connects and it was
possible to be falsely confident like
you shouldn't have been confident about
lab no one should have been confident
about lab leak early even if it turns
out to be lap league right it was always
plausible it was never definite it still
isn't definite zoonotic is is is also
quite plausible it certainly was super
plausible then
um both are politically
uncomfortable uh both were both at the
time were inflammatory to be banging on
about when we were trying to secure some
kind of cooperation from the Chinese
right so there's a time for these things
and and
and it's possible to be right by
accident right that's the that is
it Matt you're reasoning the style of
reasoning matters whether you're right
or not
you know it's like because your style of
reasoning is dictating what you're going
to do on the next topic
sure but this is a
this multivariate situation here it's
really difficult to know what's right on
kovid given all the uncertainty all the
chaos especially when you step outside
the pure biology virology of it and you
start to get into policy yeah that's
really yeah it's just trade-offs yeah
like transmissibility of the virus
sure just knowing
if 65 of the population gets vaccinated
what effect would that have
just even knowing those things just
modeling all those things
um
given all the other incentives I mean
Pfizer
but yeah you had the CEO advisor on your
podcast did you leave that conversation
feeling like
this is a person who is consciously
uh
reaping windfall profits on a dangerous
uh vaccine and putting everyone at
intolerable risk or do you think this
person did you think this person was
making a good faith attempt to save
lives and had no
no bad no uh taint of bad incentives
or something between uh the thing I
sensed and I
felt in part
it was a failure on my part
but I I sense that I was talking to a
politician
so it's not thinking of there was
malevolence there or benevolence
there was a he just had a job he put on
a suit and I was talking to a suit not a
human being
now he said that his son was a big fan
of the podcast which is why he wanted to
do it so I thought I would be talking to
a human being and I asked challenging
questions but I thought the internet
thinks otherwise every single question
in that interview
was a challenging one
but it wasn't grilling which is what
people seem to want to do with
pharmaceutical companies there's a deep
distrust of pharmaceutical companies
what what's the alternative I mean I I
totally get right that windfall profits
at a time of of you know Public Health
Emergency looks bad it's a bad it is a
bad look right but yeah what do how do
we
reward
and return Capital to to to Risk Takers
who are who will spend a billion dollars
to design a new drug for a disease
that maybe only harms of you know a
single digit percentage of the
populations like well what do we want to
encourage and who do we want to get rich
I mean so the person who cures cancer
do we want that person to get rich or
not we want the we want the person who
uh
gave us the iPhone to get rich but we
don't want the person who who cures
cancer to get rich what what are we
trying I think it's a very gray area so
what we want is the person who declares
that they have a cure for cancer to have
authenticity and transparency this like
I think we're good now as a population
smelling
and there is something about the the
Pfizer CEO for example just CEO is a
pharmaceutical companies in general just
because
they're so lowered up so much marketing
PR people that they are you just smell
you're not talking to real
human that it they just it just feels
like none of it is transparent to us as
a public so like this whole
uh talking point that Pfizer is only
interested in helping people just
doesn't ring true even though it very
well could be true it's the same thing
with Bill Gates who seems to be at scale
helping a huge amount of people in the
world and yet there's something about
the way he delivers that message well
people like
they seems suspicious what's happening
underneath this right there's certain
kinds of communication styles that seem
to uh be more
uh service better catalysts for
conspiracy theories and I'm not sure
what what that is because I don't think
there's an alternative
for capitalism
in delivering drugs that help people
but also at the same time there seems to
need to be a more transparency and plus
like regulation that actually makes
sense versus it seems like
uh pharmaceutical companies are
susceptible to corruption
yeah I I worry about all that but I I
also do think that most of the people
going into those fields and most of the
people going into government they want
to do good doing it for good and they're
non-psychopaths trying to get good
things done and try trying to solve hard
problems and they they're not trying to
get rich I mean many of the people are
it's like
they're
bad incentives or or something again
I've I've ordered that phrase 30 times
uh on this podcast but it's it's just
almost everywhere it explains normal
people creating terrible harm right it's
not that there are that many bad people
you know and
uh yes it makes it makes the truly bad
people that much more remarkable and
worth paying attention to but
the bad incentives and the bad and the
and the
the uh the power of bad ideas
to do much more harm because I mean
that's what that what that's what gets
good people running in the wrong
direction or or um
doing things that are that are clearly
creating unnecessary suffering